la moissonneuse batteuse des maires a
achevé son travail sur la base nautique
de l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
1peler faucardeuse elle a été louée par
le centre de voile pour couper les
algues présentes sur les 90 hectares
navigables du lac
on fonctionne en deux étapes à la
première étape on le voit sur la machine
ya une lame qui coupent on peut
descendre jusqu'à un mètre dix de
profondeur sur 3 m de large et donc on
fait un premier passage pour couper les
ags l'apprendra il ya peu avec le vent
on laisse le vent faire revenir les
algues au bord et après au change doute
y dépose là là mais on omet comme une
fourche à l'avant de la machine qui fait
4 mètres de large elle
et puis après on prend des grosses
brasser d'agde qui sera mené au bord
pour les déposer sur la berge qu'après
qu'ils sont évacués avec des bennes
mais alors qu'au mois de mai les ags
proliférer au point d'empêcher les
bateaux de naviguer le mauvais temps de
juillet a résolu naturellement le
problème la température de l'eau a pas
un peu baissé le niveau d'eau est monté
et cette variété a fait qu'elle a
disparu ici donc on se retrouve sur une
période où enfin quand on a pas tant que
ça
on appréhende un petit peu pour la
rentrée au mois de septembre on espère
que ce sera pas repoussé d'ici là en
attendant une éventuelle deuxième vague
d'algues à la fin de l'été la
faucardeuse rejoint quant à elle la
terre ferme